well  so far  in game one  no he had a great position of the  opening though like  he could take the pawn  um  to  move 14 maybe 12. i don't know even  later if he plays b5 instead of knight  a4 or knight a4 bishop b2 queen b2  like he he played very badly but i think  he had a great position of the opening  at least but now he's done  and they've just moved on to new  scoresheets not good for the environment  look what's the idea behind this going  oh rook f6 ah he goes to it  he goes back to f7  and i think we'll see a repetition  is this the third time king of seven  yeah and agreed to draw  god i feel bad for thing  yeah but well held by caruana  yeah karwana was very accurate in this  end game